welcome to another video my beloved
weaves today we'll recap an anime series
called corpse princess
on the night of a full moon a sleeping
guy is having a nightmare that wakes him
up when he's looking around he witnesses
a cat that enters the room and calls his
name ori he steps up and walks right
into a temple he finds an injured girl
lying in front of the great buddha he
tries to wake her up but unfortunately
this girl is already dead much to his
shock upon hearing footsteps auri
quickly hides behind the statue and
finds that his big brother covered in
bandages enters the room along with some
other priests he performs a short ritual
on the girl and hugs her miraculously
the girl comes back to life
the scene shifts to comp storming the
place of a guy named hagino as he's the
suspect who kills seven girls he jumps
right through the window of the building
while laughing next we see kay say
messing with children in a small
orphanage the man who performed the
ritual on the dead girl or he comes into
the room carrying some stuff as he's
about to leave this orphanage he
requests his friends to help him move at
school but they leave while telling him
they have club activities on the other
hand kei says talking with makina the
earlier deceased teenager reanimated as
corpse princess under the control of the
gogon sect he shows her a video of
hagino who killed the cops by using his
supernatural powers as a corpse but
police decided to suppress this incident
as they couldn't believe it meanwhile
ori bids farewell to his fellows at the
orphanage with tears in his eyes machina
infiltrates the new hiding place of
hagino only to find him sucking the
blood of young girls and claiming to be
a vampire she engages in a battle with
him using dual wielded mach 11
submachine while hagino's body turns
into a disgusting monster with wings he
captures there on flies but machina
manages to free herself and crashes down
niori she experiences a flashback where
she's chased to death by corpses upon
waking up she slaps ori and leaves with
quesay machina again storms the place
where hagino is hiding much to her
surprise she tells him about her
identity as a corpse princess tasked
with hunting down the other corpses with
evil intentions after an intense fight
machinat manages to kill the corpse by
destroying his brain as it's the only
way to kill a corpse later ori reaches
his new home only to find his sleeping
friends and decorations all around his
room after some days a tragic accident
happens and several children from the
orphanage are caught in it orie talks
with a female caretaker over the loss of
children and tries to console her casey
intervenes and tries to loosen up the
tense atmosphere by teasing him as usual
the scene shifts to the funeral ceremony
of a young girl named hikaru suddenly a
hand comes out from the casket
terrifying people while ori passes by a
hospital with a massive crowd he finds
the earlier cat who tells to follow him
upon following the cat auri again
encounters makina he continues to pursue
her secretly while she talks with kesey
over the phone about the situation at
hand upon entering a room suddenly the
corpse of hikaru attacks her injuring
her in the process just when she's about
to kill her the corpse takes on the
appearance of hikaru and hides behind
ori he takes her away while makina
suffers in pain later she steps up to
follow them even with her injuries
hikaru takes him to the park and
suddenly pushes him away revealing her
corpse nature makina discovers the
intention of the corpse and reaches the
park where hikaru is playing with other
corpse children she tells auri that
people who die with strong regret come
back alive as corpses and she's also a
corpse who exists to destroy other
corpses who threaten the peace of this
world she engages in battles and deals
some damage to them however the corpses
merge to become a giant corpse machinar
struggles against them but they
overpower her ori steps in and diverts
the corpse's attention towards himself
by showing a piece of paper makina uses
this chance to destroy them or he holds
the corpse of hikaru with grief while
making our lands the final blow that
kills her upon asking he shows her the
paper with a painting made by hikaru's
friend or he leaves while thanking her
for putting an end to this keisei
reaches the park and tells her that ori
is his adopted brother sometime later a
couple walking in the night hears a
crying baby that terrifies them suddenly
a corpse crashes into the bicycle of a
guy while machina chases the corpse only
to find that it's nowhere to be found
quesay tells her that another person has
fallen victim to this corpse later the
same cat barges into ori's house and
asks for his help
at the temple keisei and other priests
meet to find a way to stop this corpse
as five young females have already
fallen victim to it machinart notices
that something's wrong with a nearby
hospital on the other hand ori falls
unconscious near a clinic while a doctor
with a baby in hand takes him inside the
hospital later he wakes up and finds
himself in a bed upon walking outside he
witnesses machina pretending to be a
pregnant girl in front of the doctor to
investigate inside the hospital the
doctor leaves to prepare while she draws
her gun on uri to ask why he's always
around her to which he remains silent
upon following her orient is a room
where he finds a sleeping baby machina
steps in and tells him to move away
because she believes that baby is the
corpse on the other hand the doctor
loosens chains on a captured corpse to
help him defeat them makina takes the
baby and runs away but she's suddenly
attacked by a giant corpse using this
situation the doctor knocks out ori with
a bat at the laboratory casey finds that
someone has planted sales of corpses
into normal humans to convert them into
temporary corpses and all of those
corpses were mere victims he wonders
who's conducting such experiments while
swearing to capture them machina and ori
are held hostage by the doctor they
witness a giant corpse who is obeying
the doctor upon asking he tells them
that it was a girl who died giving birth
he injects some corp cells into machina
only to find that she's already a corpse
she breaks free and destroys the corpse
on the wall quickly just when she's
about to shoot the doctor or he yells
and refrains her from doing so because
he is a human later it becomes known
that the doctor was trying to perform
these experiments to prolong the
lifespan of his dying wife ksa questions
him only to find that he's been killed
we see a man licking blood on his hand
walking outside the hospital
later a famous idol named corn killed a
man in her mansion as he wasn't
listening to her song it became known
that she died of heart disease and
became a corpse but a manager used links
to suppress the news about her death her
manager receives a call from the same
man who killed the doctor he tells him
to be wary of the corpse princess on the
other hand casey tells machina about kun
and her upcoming concert he adds that
it's her chance to put an end to her
corpse machinat disguised as a pizza
delivery girl infiltrates her apartment
just when she's about to act gorn
attacks her with supersonic vocals that
throw her away mafia men surround her
but she manages to break free by showing
them her guns she shoots her with
bullets but korn's voice nullifies her
attack much to her dismay keisei also
gets cornered by mafia meme ori tries to
investigate the connection between
machinar's family and her brother he
reaches a temple with the help of the
same cat and finds a house burnt by fire
making out makes an escape by jumping
from a nearby window or he finds a
family grave and coincidentally machina
is also there she tells him to go away
but he refuses to do so because she's
heavily injured she ends up taking help
from him and together they follow the
trail of kun's corpse at a record shop
machina confronts [ __ ] who's fully
transformed into a corpse she manages to
damage her but she's at her limits uri
knocks out her manager who is trying to
distract makina suddenly casey
intervenes and hugs machina while
telling aurie that he's her contracted
priest and she can heal herself by being
near him casey plays a record of kun to
distract the corpse and fires a sacred
plant into her mouth while machina lands
the final blow with her dual weapons uri
goes home along with his brother to get
answers from him he tells him that dying
is an essential part of his world and
people who refuse to let go this world
end up becoming monsters called corpses
golgon can't exist to provide people
from these corpses or he tells him to
stop doing these dangerous things but
casey refuses telling him that it's his
responsibility on the other hand a group
of high school students steal a car
owned by an illegal renting company
however soon the car begins to move on
its own and massacres the students
inside it revealing that it's a corpse
disguised as a car the car stops at a
station where the earlier shady man's
waiting he brings out a cube to gather
the blood of the deceased students in
the car uri continues to worry about his
brother at school a new transfer student
named itsuki comes into uri's class and
begins to interact with him much to his
friend's fury his female classmates are
head over heels for a new handsome
teacher skilled in archery the scene
shifts to kesay who suspended from his
job because he revealed the secret of
the corpse princess and contracted
priest to his brother uri makinat tells
him to continue their work as they have
already researched about the car corpse
but kesey backs off saying his father
bishop has suspended him so they should
get some rest at school it's key forces
already to come with her in a rental car
by using her girly charms later that
night he comes across the cat who again
tells him to investigate this new corpse
mata uri meets up with itsuki at the
rental car side and just when they're
about to board monkey knight intervenes
and they all get in for a ride soon the
car begins to move on its own like
always and a weapon box surfaces
indicating them to fight each other and
the last one standing will survive
itsuki picks up a gun and tries to point
to uri but makina stops her telling her
this car is a corpse she attacks the car
with a dual-wielded mach 11 submachine
car falls off the cliff and makina and
uri are separated he comes across the
shady man from earlier he introduces
himself as akasha commonly known as the
betrayer monk he tells him that corpse
princesses can go to heaven after
killing a hundred and eight corpses
suddenly itsuki steps in with pistols
revealing that she's also a corpse
princess she attacks akasha but he
dodges them the new teacher makes an
appearance revealing himself to be the
contracted priest of itsuki the scene
shifts to the bar we already worked as a
priest we get to see the bar owner mibu
a contracted priest commonly known as
auditor he has permission to kill humans
using his corpse princesses the priest
from the kogon cult arrives at the bar
to tell him that he must dispose of ori
and kesay if they turn out to be
traitors mubu's corpse princess named
akira picks up his sniper rifle and
leaves for their mission on the other
hand itsuki together with a contracted
priest is fighting the betrayer monk
they tell uri to run away as he's just a
burden to them in a rage akasha
activates his forbidden zardan technique
to capture itsuki and while running uri
comes across makina who's still fighting
the car corbs he continues to ask
questions about her goal and why he
should stay away from his brother the
car corps captures machina and strangles
her brutally amidst their talk casey
comes riding on his bike and freezer by
cutting her arm with a hidden knife the
car transforms into a full-fledged
corpse and machina destroys the corpse's
brain upon hearing about the betrayer
among famouri they run to help the
itsuki team they find itsuki trapped in
the technique of akasha while the
teacher is heavily injured makina helps
her in escaping and together they begin
to fight him upon discovering a chant kc
steps in and takes the cube that
appeared when makina killed the corpse
but he's unable to move because the cube
holds the blood of a hundred and eight
corpses casey asks him why he killed his
corpse princess when he loved her very
much to which he replies that the go
gone cult betrayed him just then akasha
is about to kill keisei with his sword
he uses the cube to defend the attack
revealing that he took a potion called
soma the cube breaks and blood splashes
on both causing keisei to lose
consciousness mibu along with the corpse
princess fires a bullet towards akasha
causing him to retreat maki now promises
to uri that she'll not let kesey die
while holding him with a crying look on
her face
can kce survive these deadly wounds
continue watching from episode 7 to
discover more